you have to keep turning the flywheel so
if you heard that analogy by Jim Collins
really good analogy right so once you've
got everything working the key at that
point is about execution and
optimization so I think it's really
really important to understand the the
infrastructure or the the um the
foundations you have to put in place to
be able to get a business to the point
where you can start to scale really
really aggressively once you've got
those foundations in place which we've
we've been doing at strive for for a
couple of years now
starts to get really really exciting
I do want to lie I do want to talk about
strive here because I've kind of seen
this movie before because I saw it in my
Channel I didn't necessarily know it at
the time but I've seen this movie before
and I Know How It Ends and
you know that might sound a bit boring
but the ending's really really good
um and the journey that you go through
to get that ending is absolutely amazing
I think one of the things that we did at
liquid was we we wanted to make a dent
in the universe and at the beginning we
were just 20 people in a room that said
let's become the best in the world at
what we do and that was quite compelling
for us because we said right there's
some established players in this place
we're gonna take on we're just this
small recruitment Company in Manchester
and back then all of our competitors
were based in London
they were big they'd been around for a
long time they were really really
established and what we did was we were
just 20 people and we sat in a room and
said right we are going to make a dent
in this universe and we're going to
become the market leader within 10 years
we're going to take on and beat every
single one of those established players
in this space and we're going to make a
dent in the universe and at the end of
this journey we're going to be able to
say that we took this business from
nothing effectively to being the very
very best in the world of what we do
we're in exactly that same place at this
moment in time at strive and that's why
I'm so Keen to you know build my profile
online and maybe get a bit of
recognition for what the guys that
strive are doing because it's a really
congested crowded Market at the moment
and
there's so many recruitment companies
out there that look and sound the same
but they're not the same that that's not
me in any way being critical of other
recruitment companies far from it but
I've seen this movie before I know where
we go from here such an exciting time to
get in on the ground level in a business
like this because we're about to go
through that hyper growth stage
so I'm really really Keen to sort of
shout from the the raft of the the
rafters whatever that saying is and
really sort of
subscribe to people what that
opportunity is and hopefully get them as
excited as we are about where we're
going as an organization the recruitment
mentors podcast is proudly sponsored by
vincere and the award-winning Source
breaker